those are you look cool thanks you see
that yes who's funny
I'm much cooler with my hat I definitely
do believe that
[Music]
please
[Music]
that's what's going to end up having
them easily that's what's happening on
that like that's what daily being a
scary B's about right like I've been so
right to store clean like now I'm just
not going to lead I need to bathe for it
or lost in history or me having to say I
said it so like it's just going to be
there right
there's also let me add it here actually
because it's a very smart statement for
business people the other thing that
musically should consider or should be
considered right now is the fact that
Facebook the fact that Facebook are
successfully pivoted to being a mobile
first platform years ago is the biggest
reason it's a winning company today
Tumblr and Pinterest leaders in a 2011
12 13 world were unable to become as
dominant in Mobile which opened the door
for Instagram and snapchat and so what
music we may be able to do is become a
disproportionate leader in something
like voice in something like in
something that I can't even think of
right now that is a platform shift and
so some great some big change that uh
that changes the paradigm for them that
that you need to make those big moves at
time to find opportunity and right now
as of the writing of this book I think
they need something big to gain momentum
especially up in that 12 to 17 year old
crowd to start growing into that area
the only thing you're risking by taking
these roots is your time the upside of
being right about one of the pillar
content and pillar social networks and
being a first mover
is life-changing the downside is you
wasted time and who are you to be so
fancy about your time that's the
punchline set like everybody's so
[ __ ] like all these people that want
to break out all these people that want
to live the life all these see what I
want all this great [ __ ] happens that
they're not willing to risk their time
for that upside in case it's MySpace or
buying instead of Facebook or Instagram
who the [ __ ] are they like you're a
beggar you don't get to choose right
[ __ ] beggar you like want to not be
an accountant anymore you want to be
America's beekeeper so you're telling me
that you're not willing to take the chip
you are willing to write off musically
right now while you're reading this [ __ ]
you
[Music]
landed in Montreal this morning from the
red-eye got a couple hours of sleep got
a nice little gym session in with Jordan
and then was upstairs did a bunch of
business calls or good stuff some cool
new Facebook commercials coming out of
vaynermedia that I'm really proud of I
hope and then hey do with me one sec
going and then come on that door and
then we keep it don't worry
thank you and then and then had a nice
two-hour session with Stephanie land my
ghostwriter we're finishing up crushed
it which will come out in January looks
like of 18 so I'm excited about that the
follow-up to the book that kind of put
me on the map and now I'm in the green
room about to rip everybody's [ __ ]
faces off in Montreal and that's that
time and flesh in the real flag the real
freaking flesh mom Hale good I'm great
man and I'm excited for your your sports
Bryn there oh yeah we're excited that I
mean there's a Samuel Dalembert here to
the player yeah I came to support his
friends also man I know you're busy so I
read like smelling a strap-on I can't
wait
of course there was that weird when I
fell I can care less
thank you
[Music]
right on Twitter yes yes you give me
advice how to make my visits I'm
starting to go full-time because I
really wanted my become a copywriter
full-time with the specific niche I also
want to write books as a living without
working like that nine-to-five like
doing anything with by eating it's by
eating [ __ ] up front so that you can win
later yeah I mean it's like what are you
gonna do at midnight tonight yeah I'm
going to do it I always do it after
school and I'm just getting exposure
it's about getting exposure and hosting
on medium LinkedIn your own blog facial
typing an incredible play just write
copy so it's just hacking it's like it's
like how do I get muscle you work out
every day
yes got it yeah for sure thanks
you got a studio here but it looks great
yep and it's a worthwhile attempt but to
this my opinion other people's opinion
it's all execution Facebook 90% people
fall asleep its snapchat 90% of people
thought if it's Twitter 99% of people
thought it was stupid
regardless of what any would see you got
to get this out and we asked to what
people react to thank you you thank you
very all you have here you showed thank
you cook for you thank you my also do
bunny buddy it siren demand for not
probably call pourquoi pas put trouble
three gap between the word coaches that
equals the fruit of life culture presume
in wisdom quotes of Montreal Anderson I
look up to guys like got Harrison yeah
Adam Braun yes I know then my career is
yeah exactly my question is like what
makes me met and support like these guys
not you pursue my I want to get keeping
your mind on top what I would do it yeah
because I don't think they're full of
[ __ ] I think there are 100 percent
honest the baffle fact that they want to
do good but they don't disguise what
they care about themselves good but my
general people try to be altruistic and
be like I just want to save the world
will you know got it got it
of course I guys yeah yeah ok cool I
mean that's not to the point I mean look
I think but also as you know were
meeting so successful on the field was
when nobody was watching off the deal
right
so you're talking about the game I get
tapped and feedback when I go on stage
right now I'm gonna get feedback so you
see where I'm going
I know what you did in the weight room
and what you were doing when nobody was
watching and I think that's what
entrepreneurship is I get all this a
little bit my normal 18 hours is what I
was doing in the hotel room for last
five hours putting out fires making
business viewers running an organization
so I do you think there's similarity I
think it's somebody who
disproportionately brings value
other people which then allows them to
have those people's attention and I
think the best purebred influencers know
what to do with that attention my
biggest concern is that there's a lot of
influencers who are doing a lot of
selfish behavior with their attention
it's all about themselves and I think
that that will ultimately play itself
out and give them a short run but for me
the ultimate influencer is a guy or gal
that understands that people to care
about you forever
you've got to disproportionately bring
them more value than you're asking for
in return get energy here at Montreal a
lot of influencers include some
marketing everybody wants to be
influencer before they actually do the
thing that gives them the influence
that's an investigation so it's got to
make sure until it home to this audience
of like work skills craft value patience
some nice concoction needs in
everybody's attacking it with
you know we're going on
[Applause]
[Applause]
preciate it
that was nice it's interesting to me
that what continues to run through my
mind is that the words being absolutely
you know and that action need everywhere
that the scariest thing for me is that
there are hundreds of millions of people
who have the word entrepreneur and
influencer in their Instagram account
and think that that means they are one
and so glad people are clapping back
shut up because the truth because what's
happening in our space and it's amazing
to have professional athletes here's
that's like we say basketball player and
writing it in my Instagram profile I
play basketball I don't get paid to play
basketball
they have we never get how to run a
Facebook ad for the wind community or
create a snapchat filter or how to start
a podcast the information is free at
your fingertips and if you are not savvy
enough or willing to put in the work to
be able to do a google search and
consume it you might as well leave this
[ __ ] room right so she basically
again a little hard here is she's
basically asking how do you compete when
the people you're competing with have a
ton of money you don't you have no
choice
I think another question now now that
I've done my dramatic pause will be play
that question only [ __ ] with me because
guess what Apple the smallest [ __ ] to
like every brand and business and person
that isn't ever one was zero so its
execution my best work is when I have
limited resources I was at my best in
early while I think this was in [ __ ]
dailyvee as a 22 year old with Wine
Library because then none of you would
have any tonight $14,000 to spend for
the year in marketing after I sold a
bunch of wine to be able to even have
that which meant I just stood in a
liquor store for 15 hours a day and
people would walk in wanting to buy one
bottle of wine and I hustled them for
three if we just grinding I didn't
[ __ ] Instagram and get a lucky
hashtag
so sorry so social so you know when I
was doing female when nobody was doing
here like when you are nothing or little
you're writing her back because you have
no choice yeah when you remove you get
lazy and fat montreux I gotta go play
but I think I need to take advantage of
that and there's millions of people like
that so for me they have all the
advantages of all the relationships and
then the same thing that got them to the
highest level of sports is all the hard
work it's just hard work like it's like
all this was hard work this is a
manifestation of I've been working since
I was 14 years old every [ __ ] day you
know what I mean 27 years is 27 years in
the making 47 years in the making
and I don't think people understand that
super successful week
intense San Francisco Chicago Kansas
City Kansas of you to Detroit to
Columbus Ohio Columbus Ohio the Dallas
the biggest red eye for Vegas come on
trio now i'll wrapping up late night
friday to new york city shortens guys
eyes closed hate it I just looked at you
oh my children's line yeah so we do it
around here yeah
thinking about all of us thank you so
much thank you my friends I'm heading
into the airport here in Montreux we've
got a big breakthrough de rock and I
just had a moment if you follow me on
snapchat stories and Instagram stories
you're just even agree literally just
have a breakthrough moment of the audio
experience the Gary Vee audio experience
which is every day for filming all day
and there's gold original content that
can be used for the audio experience of
the podcast but we're editing with only
intent for the blog service over here I
could fit every day you Tyler Justin
whoever iris we're going to find good
chunks where we may use a minute of it
but in 9 minute and 13 second form is
complete thought it could be an
incredible original piece of content of
the audio experience so that's what
we're doing today Montreal kind of like
flew in give a keynote around the
influence of marketing but what I really
wanted to focus on in this episode of
the podcast is I stood hour and a half
two hours with Stephanie land my
ghostwriter
and we started creating I've run third
base on our next book crushed it which
is the follow-up to the breakthrough
book question of my career the updated
version of what to do on other platforms
so that's what we focused on today so
we're listening to now some raw footage
of the behind the scenes that we
manifest in January 2018 New York Times
best-selling book crushed it
yeah I'm out of here see a Montreal
beautiful day people time miss you
haven't been here a whole bunch Toronto
Vancouver been getting more of the
Canadian love but I might I'm 15 it was
good
so Jordan was okay do you wrap a solid I
was phenomenal
[Music]